what I was studying um in law school
when I ran out of First Amendment
classes um I decided to study censorship
during the Tudor dynasty uh because
that's where we get our ideas of prior
restraint uh that come from the
licensing of the printing press which
was something that Henry VII was the
first to do where basically
um the idea was that if you can't print
anything in England unless it's with
these uh your majesty approved printers
um it will prevent heretical work and
anti-henry VII stuff from coming out
pretty pretty pretty pretty pretty
pretty
um efficient idea if nothing else
um and I always and so he started
getting angry at the printing press
around 1521 and then passed something
um that required prints to be along with
parliament in 1538.
uh and I always think of that as kind of
like where we are now
um because we have this we have the back
then we had the original disruptive
technology you know writing was probably
real bad but the next one which which
was the printing press which was
absolutely calamitous and I mean and I
and I say calamitous on purpose because
in the short term the witch hunts went
up like crazy because the printing press
allowed you to get that manual and how
to find witches
um that the religious wars went crazy
um it led to all sorts of distress
misinformation nastiness
and Henry VII was trying to put the
genie back in the bottle you know he was
kind of like I I can I can I want to use
this for good like uh like I feel like
it could it could be used
but he was in an unavoidable period of
epistemic Anarchy there's nothing you
can do to make the period after the
printing press come uh came out to be a
non-disruptive non-crazy period other
than like absolute totalitarianism and
destroy all the print presses which
simply was not possible in Europe
so I feel like that's kind of like where
we are now that disruption came from
adding I think you know several million
people to the European conversation and
then eventually the global conversation
but eventually it became the best tool
for discomformation
um for getting rid of falsity for
spotting bad ideas and it's the benefits
the long-term benefits of the printing
press are incalculally great
um and that's what gives me some
optimism for where we are now with
social media because we are in that
unavoidably anarchical period And I do
worry that that there um uh that there
are attempts in states to pass things to
try to put the genie back in the bottle
like if we ban a tick tock or we uh say
that
um nobody under 18 can be on on the
internet unless they have parental
permission we're going at something that
no amount of sort of top down is going
to be able to fix it we have to
culturally adapt to the fact of it
um uh in ways that make us wiser that
actually um and allow it potentially to
be that wonderful engine for
disconfirmation that we're nowhere near
yet by the way but think about it
additional millions of eyes on problems
um thanks to the printing press helped
create the Scientific Revolution the
enlightenment the discovery of ignorance
um
we now have added billions of eyes and
voices to solving problems and we're
just we're using them for cat videos and
canceling
but that those are just the early days
of the printing press it all starts with
the cats and the canceling is there
something about X about Twitter
which is perhaps the most uh energetic
source of cats and canceling it seems
like the collective unconscious of the
species I mean like
it's one of these things where the
tendency to want to see patterns in
history sometimes can limit
the actual batshit crazy experience of
what history actually is because yes we
we have these nice comforting ideas that
it's going to be like last time we don't
know it it it it hasn't happened yet and
I think
how unusual Twitter is because I think
of it as like the uh because because
people talk about you know writing and
mass communications and uh as being
expanding the size of our Collective
brain but now we're kind of looking at
our Collective brain in real time and
it's filled just like our own brains
with all sorts of like little crazy
things that pop up and and and appear
like virtual particles kind of all over
the place of people
um you know reacting in real time to
things there's never been anything even
vaguely like it and it can be at its
worst awful to see at its best sometimes
seeing people like just getting euphoric
over something going on and cracking
absolutely brilliant immediate jokes you
know at the same time it can be it can't
even be a joyful experience
um I I feel like uh and uh I live in a
neighborhood now on X where I I mostly
deal with people that I I think are
actually thoughtful even if I disagree
with them
um and and it's not such a bad
experience I occasionally run into those
other sort of what I call neighborhoods
on X where it's just all canceling all
nastiness and it's always kind of an
unpleasant visit to those places I'm not
saying the whole thing needs to be uh
like like my experience but I do think
that the reason why people keep on
coming back to it is it reveals raw
aspects of humanity that sometimes we
prefer to pretend don't exist
yeah but also it's totally new like you
said yeah it's just the virality the
speed the news travels the opinions
travel that the battle over ideas
travels the battle over information too
yeah of what is true and not lies travel
the old Mark Twain thing pretty fast on
the thing yeah and then it changes your
understanding of how to interpret
information it could also stress you out
you know and I remember to get off it
sometimes the stats are pretty bad on
Mental Health uh with with young people
and I'm definitely in the camp of people
who think that social media is part of
that I understand you know the debate
but I'm pretty persuaded that one of the
things that is hasn't been great for
mental health I mean of people is is
just constantly being exposed yeah
absolutely I I think it's possible to
create social media that makes a huge
amount of money makes people happy to me
like it's possible to align yeah the the
incentives so in terms of yeah making
teenagers making uh every stage of life
giving you long-term fulfillment and
happiness with your physical existence
outside of the social media and on
social media helping you grow as a human
being helping challenge you just in the
right amount and just the right amount
of cat videos whatever gives this full
Rich Human Experience I think it's just
a machine learning problem it's like
it's not easy to create a feed so the
easiest feed you could do is like
maximize engagement yeah but that's just
like a really dumb algorithm yeah it's
like for the for the algorithm to learn
enough about you to understand what will
make you truly happy as a human being to
grow long term that's just a very
difficult problem to solve you ever
watch fleabag it's absolutely brilliant
uh British show
um and it sets you up one of the reasons
why like people love it so much is it
sets you up that you're watching like a
a raunchy British Sex in the City except
the main character is the the most
promiscuous one
um it's like okay and you kind of roll
your eyes a little bit out it's kind of
funny and it's kind of cute and kind of
spicy
and then you realize that the person is
actually kind of suffering and having a
hard time and it gets deeper and deeper
as the show goes on and she will do
these incredible speeches about tell me
what to do like I just I know there's
experts out there I know there's
knowledge out there I know there's an
optimal way to live my life so why can't
someone just tell me what to do and and
it's this wonderfully like
um
accurate I think uh aspect of human
desire that what if something could
actually tell me the optimal way to go
because I think there is a desire to
give up some amount of your own freedom
and discretion in order to be told to do
the optimally right thing but that path
scares me to death yeah we see the way
you phrase it that's miscares me too so
there's several things one you could be
constantly distracted in a tick tock Way
by things that keep you engaged yeah so
removing that and giving you a bunch of
options constantly and learning from
long term what results in your actual
long-term happiness so like which
amounts of challenging ideas are good
for you uh that you know for somebody
like me
[Laughter]
just for but there is a number like that
for you yeah Greg like for me that
number is pretty high I love debate I
love I I love the feeling of like
realizing holy I've been wrong yes
but like you know and I would love for
the algorithm to know that about me and
to help me but always giving me options
if I want to descend into cat videos and
so on well the educational aspect of it
yes education yes like the idea of kind
of like both going the speed that you
need to and running as fast as you can
yeah you know I mean there's that you
know the whole flow thing I just feel it
YouTube recommendation
for for better or worse if used
correctly it feels like it does a pretty
good job whenever I just refuse to click
on stuff that's just dopamine based and
click on only educational things yeah
the recommendation provides are really
damn good so I feel like it's a solvable
problem at least in this in the space of
Education of challenging yourself but
also expanding your realm of knowledge
and all this kind of stuff and I'm
definitely more in the we're an
inescapably anarchical period and it
will require big cultural adjustments
and there's gonna there's no way that
this isn't gonna be difficult transition